bienvenidos a este primer vídeo y en
realidad es el primer vídeo en una lista
de temas de ecuaciones diferenciales sé
que ya hablé un poco de esto cuando
vimos movimiento armónico y creo que
cuando tocamos algunos otros temas pero
ahora como ustedes me lo han pedido
vamos a abarcar el tema completo y esto
es una cosa bastante útil porque las
ecuaciones diferenciales es algo que
aparece en distintos en diferentes
campos de hecho son muchísimos los lados
en donde aparecen me lo han pedido gente
que están comenzando por estudiar un
doctorado en economía me lo ha pedido
gente que está entrando en física que
van a entrar a carreras de ingeniería
por lo que es un área de estudio
ampliamente aplicable así que vamos a
comenzar antes de que me siga
distrayendo entonces la primera pregunta
es qué es una ecuación diferencial y
ustedes saben lo que es una ecuación
pero una ecuación diferencial que es
bueno una ecuación diferencial es algo
que implica una función desconocida y
además sus derivadas digamos que yo
tengo
ya prima
si ya prima más de esto que sea igual a
x 3
aquí aquí la función desconocida el
hielo podríamos haber escrito a lo mejor
de otra forma por ejemplo gtx o escrito
como del de x + d
e igual a x 3
también podríamos haberlo puesto con efe
es verdad efe prima de x + f x igual a x
3 así que todas estas son formas válidas
de escribir exactamente la misma
ecuación diferencial y lo que es
interesante aquí y digamos que es el
punto de partida de lo que ya hemos
aprendido sobre ecuaciones regulares es
esto
déjenme escribirles una ecuación normal
solo para que recuerden una ecuación
regular digamos si tuviéramos una
variable no sé x cuadrada más el coseno
de x es igual a la raíz cuadrada de x
bueno lo que acabamos de inventar es la
solución la solución de esta ecuación es
un número a veces un conjunto de números
verdad porque puede haber varios si
tenemos un polinomio podríamos tener
varios valores de x que satisfacen eso
aquí la la solución de una ecuación
diferencial es una función nuestro
objetivo es averiguar qué función de xy
aquí yo escribí fx explícitamente pero
qué función de x satisface esta relación
o esta ecuación
así que déjenme mostrarles lo que quiero
decir con esto ya aquí tengo a la mano
mi libro de ecuaciones diferenciales de
la universidad que vamos a utilizar
conforme avancemos así que vamos a decir
que solo estoy escribiendo esta ecuación
diferencial y hay que no no voy a
mostrarles necesariamente cómo
resolverlo en este momento porque
tenemos que aprender algunos trucos
primero pero creo que es un buen lugar
para empezar que entendamos lo que es
una ecuación diferencial para que no te
confundas con ecuaciones tradicionales
por lo tanto ellas tienen en las
ecuaciones diferenciales tenemos
derivadas digamos esta es la segunda
derivada de yemas dos veces la primera
derivada de y menos cinco menos tres
veces igual a cero nos dan las
soluciones aquí y ellos quieren que
hagamos mostrar que son soluciones y
creo que es una buena idea para empezar
a comprender lo que es una ecuación
diferencial y lo que implica su solución
nos dicen que uno de x igual a ea la
menos 3x es una solución se afirma que
es una solución así que vamos a
a mostrar que esto es cierto así que si
si tomamos
déjenme escribirlo así la primera
derivada de 1 quién es la primera
derivada pues bueno simplemente por
regla de la cadena esto es la menos 3x
por la derivada de lo que está arriba
que es menos 3 verdad es la derivada de
la función interna así que hay que
multiplicar esta función por menos 3
y la segunda derivada de uno bueno pues
simplemente tomamos la derivada de lo
anterior que será menos tres por menos 3
que es 9 que a la menos 3 x verdad y ahí
sólo vamos a comprobar que sí sí si
sustituimos estas tres expresiones en la
ecuación original
esto nos nos cumple la igualdad así que
la lo que tenemos es que prima que es 9
ea la menos 3x más dos veces de prima
que va a ser más dos veces menos tres
por ea la menos tres x verdad eso era lo
que era prima y les un perdón hay que
restarle tres veces ya que es la menos 3
x ésta es la que estamos tomando como
solución y vamos a ver que nos da esto a
esto que es igual tenemos 9 era la menos
3 x menos 6
a la menos 3 x menos tres a menos tres
equis y ahora sí bueno esto es a 9 lo
que sea menos 6 lo que sea menos 3 lo
que sea bueno esto es igual a 0 verdad
así que fue igual a 0 no importa el
punto es que se comprobó que para esta
función de 1 igual a ea la menos 3 x se
satisface la ecuación diferencial para
esta función ahora que hay algo
interesante y lo as lo hemos visto en en
ecuaciones regulares y es que esto
probablemente no es la única solución de
hecho aprenderemos a lo mejor en uno o
dos vídeos que a menudo la solución no
es sólo una sino podría ser toda una
clase de funciones que son el mismo tipo
de función pero difieren por alguna
constante para hacerlos mostrar es
después aquí realmente lo que quiero es
que vean lo que es una solución y que de
hecho podemos probar que esta segunda
función de x de 2 de x igual a ea la x
nada más
también es solución y como comprobamos
bueno la primera y la segunda derivada
de a la x quiénes son
a la equis verdad así que la segunda
derivada que sea la equis más dos veces
la primera derivada que 'quienes pues
simplemente la primera derivada es la
equis por lo tanto tenemos dos ea la x
menos tres veces la función que es menos
tres a la equis y aquí tenemos a la x
más 12 a la x menos tres de alak x que
es cero por lo que ésta también es una
solución de esta ecuación diferencial
también es una solución
ahora antes de que sigamos vamos antes
de que podamos decir cómo resolver
algunas ecuaciones creo que es buen
momento con la esperanza de que tengas
mayor noción de lo que es una ecuación
diferencial y lo que es su solución creo
que es que además no es un número es un
conjunto de funciones o quizás una
función o una clase de funciones es buen
momento para entrar en terminología así
que hay dos grandes clasificaciones
bueno de hecho hay una una grande
primero que son las ecuaciones
ordinarias y parciales una ecuación
diferencial ordinaria es la que ya
escribí antes que es una variable con
respecto a otra o una función con
respecto a digamos xy sus derivadas las
parciales eso es más complicado porque
es cuando una función puede depender
demás variables digamos que dependa de x
de jay-z no nos vamos a preocupar por
ellas ahorita aquí las funciones y sus
derivadas van a depender sólo de una
variable y estamos hablando de
ecuaciones diferenciales ordinarias
y eso es lo que en este vídeo vamos a
ver ecuaciones diferenciales ordinarias
ahora en las ecuaciones diferenciales
ordinarias hay dos maneras de
clasificarlas y son son son de la
siguiente forma primero tenemos su orden
cuál es el orden de una ecuación
diferencial bueno esa es una pregunta y
la otra es si son lineales o no lineales
y creo que la mejor forma de ver esto es
simplemente dar ejemplos así que déjenme
anotar uno
digamos que esto lo estoy sacando de mi
libro de ecuaciones diferenciales de la
universidad así que digamos que tenemos
x cuadrada por la segunda derivada de ye
respecto de x ambas veces y demás x que
multiplica la primera derivada de ye
respecto de x + 2 e igual a seno de x
entonces la primer pregunta aquí es cuál
es el orden y el y el orden es la
derivada mayor que existe en tu ecuación
ok entonces la derivada más alta de la
de esta ecuación la solución va a ser
una de x que satisface esta ecuación y
el orden de la ecuación es la derivada
más alta en este caso es la segunda
derivada verdad es la más alta por lo
que esta ecuación tiene orden 2 muy bien
digamos que también es una ecuación de
segundo grado ajá de segundo orden ahora
la segunda cosa es que tenemos que ver
si es una ecuación lineal o no lineal
así que una ecuación diferencial es
lineal si todas las funciones y sus
derivadas son esencialmente bueno por
falta de de una palabra mejor lineal es
que quiero decir con eso me refiero a
que no tengo que cuadrada
no tengo la derivada de jr respecto de x
al cuadrado no tengo ya que multiplica
la segunda derivada en fin este es un
ejemplo donde tengo una ecuación lineal
de segundo orden porque tenemos la
segunda derivada
y además bueno la primera también y ya
pero no se están multiplicando por la
función o sus derivadas ahora sí esta
ecuación yo yo yo pongo otra ecuación
digamos x cuadrada x
la segunda derivada de ye respecto de x
ambas veces y esto que sea igual al seno
de x pero déjenme elevar la segunda
derivada al cuadrado ahora aquí tengo
una ecuación diferencial no lineal esta
la anterior era lineal esta es no lineal
porque leve al cuadrado lo que era la
segunda derivada verdad la multiplique
por sí misma digamos otro ejemplo de una
ecuación no lineal es si yo pongo ye por
la segunda derivada de ye respecto de x
ambas veces ajá y que esto fuera igual
hace 9 x ésta también es una ecuación no
lineal porque multiplicamos a la segunda
derivada por la función que es verdad
aquí lo hemos multiplicado por algo que
depende de la variable independiente
digamos de x pero de todos modos se me
está terminando el tiempo ojalá te dé
por lo menos un buen panorama de lo que
es una ecuación diferencial en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a comenzar a
resolverlas nos vemos pronto